archaeologists on the southwestern tip
of Europe are digging up dramatic
secrets about the lives of our ancient
ancestors their research shows
Neanderthals shared many behaviors long
considered unique to humans today the
discoveries are taking place inside a
cave complex recently declared a World
Heritage Site
Jonathan Vigliotti takes us inside
Gorham's cave in Gibraltar to walk where
Neanderthals once did along this rugged
coast a few hundred steps can transport
you thousands of years back in time
we're here on the southern tip of
Gibraltar famous rock heading to a place
called Gorham's cave once the home of
our early ancestors and today the home
of some really amazing research this is
the place where Neanderthals are
believed to have lived out their final
days on earth before mysteriously
vanishing the Neanderthals are our
closest extinct relatives just another
branch on our family tree the last
evidence of their existence was found in
Gibraltar dating back 30 2000 years when
you walk here can you imagine the and
earth I was living here tens of
thousands of years ago absolutely I
often think that they were so like us
they probably sat in the same places and
looked out of the same view and really
all that's separating us his time
archaeologist Geraldine Finland s'en and
her team have been excavating mankind's
past life since 1989 after a child and
adult in the and earth all skull were
found here it's safe to say this cave
has a lot of Secrets hidden in it yes
but it's also a generous cave it gives a
it gives up a little bit of its secrets
every time back when Neanderthals lived
here the rock was surrounded by a beach
over 40 thousand years of wind blowing
sand into the caves and rising sea
levels trapped the artifacts inside
until now the findings have revealed a
life remarkably similar to ours little
black flecks in it those black flakes
are little bits of charcoal that have no
when you have a barbecue it spits so did
this used to be the kitchen for
Neanderthals it would have been for that
group
so now what is back here in 2014 her
team's discovery just up these stairs
now sealed off to protect it proved
Neanderthals were capable of abstract
thinking once thought impossible it's
called the hash tag a series of lines
deliberately carved into stone
deliberately as an art deliberately as
in a conscious decision to make an
impression on the rock whether they were
trying to communicate a message as art
or a message as I don't know a
rudimentary map we will never really
know what scientifically so I always
stopped short of saying it's at we're
looking at the beginning of the
expression of the human race you know
expressing themselves so what are we
looking at here what that expression
helped give the cave system UNESCO World
Heritage status last year and the best
way to see it all is from a distance
we've catalogued over 200 caves in
Gibraltar not all of them have
Neanderthals but over 200 caves on the
rock now 10 of those have direct
evidence of Neanderthal presence you
could say that this is a bit like
Neanderthal City a lost city slowly
unearthed it's almost like a time
capsule
well yes I wouldn't I'd never thought of
it that way but absolutely this is
exactly what it is you're walking on
exactly the same place that the
Neanderthals were walking and you're
finding the little bits of evidence that
have left them survived the ages it's
still unclear what caused Neanderthals
to go extinct but if this hashtag is a
clue what other clues from our past are
waiting to be found for CBS this morning
Jonathan Vigliotti Tripp Walter